hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to prison architect now
this is really gonna be interesting
because I don't know what else there is
to tell about the story of this game but
I'm eager to find out it's really
interesting because it caught me so
quickly off-guard I knew that it was
gonna be about building prison and I
kind of like exploded about this last
episode but I wanted to collect my
thoughts and reiterate it more I did not
know this was this type of game and
that's why it caught me so off guard and
that's why suddenly I'm very excited to
play it because I usually don't get
surprised going into a game it's
fascinating to me that it started off
this way I mean obviously it's simple if
you think about it the idea of a prison
is kind of a touchy subject it involves
incarcerated human beings and they have
thoughts and feelings too and they have
backstories even if they did commit
crimes they have the real people
demolishing those buildings will take a
while you can pass the time more quickly
by using the buttons under the clock
okay I already knew about that if
there's one thing markiplier knows it's
how to pass the time without actually
putting any work into it so that's
besides the point but I need to cure or
hire some doctors because apparently
where's my infirmary there we go
apparently poink do I just need the one
oh they're healing up oh it's still
Vicks still have their hoses man those
are some epic hoses on those firemen
alright so those firemen are gonna be
dismissed and I got a doctor in here
that can help the dawn however the hell
that happened
I imagine that someone started the fire
to try to kill the dawn but I don't know
about that hire more workmen to speed up
demolition okay I can do that man that's
a lot of workmen already where do I put
them I guess I can put them in storage I
suppose boink boink boink wow look at
him go they're all tired too bad work
harder you slaves
I run a prison here not a charity case
ah okay anyway but I can take care of
this dawn he is my baby and I shall love
him
forever Wow I can zoom in real close
alrighty then
so we got that we need to hire a couple
of doctors sorry I did not know that
boink okay so now we got two lovely
doctors [ __ ] didn't mean to do that
now we got three doctors for no reason
sack sack fine good work thank you let's
check up on our casualty Oh
oh boy he's turning into two-face
Peabody boop beep boop boop
oh well that don't look good those
better be his oh they here to finish him
off oh oh oh oh oh hey dawn oh hey how's
it going
Lily orgies I think he's trying to say
something what cheese which of you [ __ ]
oh my god oh whoa
dawn calm down not a big deal you just
got burned alive
it's fine no one did this to you Pappy
it was an accident
oh jeez God calm down
dawn jeez oh shut your stinking mouth
and listen good the both of you if I
knew which one of you [ __ ] started that
fire I'd snap your stinking neck but my
time is done I'm gonna die in this
[ __ ] bed and there's a family
business to run the palermo name is all
we've got left so you do the honorable
thing you dirty piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
capiche uh yeah we capisce we capisce
real good we know what to do Pop's huh
why is he in jail with both of his sons
that's a good question oh man oh man
these take turns who everybody my
reviver Erica
watch your [ __ ] back this isn't over
Nico oh okay Oh without food yeah let's
just shift gears here don't worry about
all that was happening mr. CEO don't you
worry your pretty little beard about it
without food these inmates will be
tearing down the walls within a couple
days we've got to secure the prison
before we end up with a riot on our
hands this is the deployment screen from
here you can control the tactical
deployment of all your guards
well handi-vac i like this deploy and
spread the guards with all the cell box
and rooms assigned 10 guards to stations
around the prison that should be
sufficient show of strength for now I
also don't want a Patrol I want a patrol
in the inner courtyard where we'll be
building the new facilities okay words
are getting harder to say any time
you're unsure what to do highlight the
objective and you'll see additional
instructions
all righty then let's deploy the guards
out see no canteens accessible no
canteens wait guard patrols I was
supposed to have guards patrolling the
inner courtyard but mine and yeah
that'll be good patrols probably I hope
so maybe maybe not right how about this
oh I can do that wink wink wink wink
wink wink wink wink wink and that's all
I need that's ten yeah I did it okay
wait I thought hey can i Wu hey wait a
minute
ah oh yeah I don't know how I did that
but I did it good yeah I'm good at
playing this game probably not we've a
lot of work still to do we need to turn
our attention to replace him kitchen in
the canteen maybe that should have been
the first priority that we should have
done before we worried about riots on
our hands first we need to rebuild the
kitchen you'll need to install several
pieces of equipment and hire some chefs
once that done build a new canteen once
you have all that and completed the
chefs will automatically start preparing
meals for the entire prison handy that
they're nice if you aren't sure what to
do at any time try highlighting the
objective in the dualist to see some
hints do you not know who I am my name
is markiplier and I absolutely never
follow any instructions and I just go
willy-nilly on what I want to do and
then complain when things don't go my
way so mr. CEO you back the [ __ ] off
thank you very much okay so we need to
build a kitchen which I'm gonna figure
out right about now I'm gonna build it
in the shadow of the destroyed version
haha well [ __ ] I can't you do I can't
seem to do that why can't I do that
what's wrong what's the big deal why
can't I build a kitchen here I'm trying
real hard it's why isn't it letting me
build a kitchen wait a minute something
ain't right here what this is this is
some baloney here I'm not much
appreciating this how the Frick do I'd
why is it not doing maybe can't know it
doesn't know what do you want from me
indoors cooker fridge Oh duh I'm stupid
I need to build the building first da
man I'm so silly
oh man I almost completely forgot about
that you actually need the building
first and then you can put things inside
of it so now I need to build the room
with the kitchen but this needs to
actually be built first it can't be
built yet it's ooh not quite there
so objects large jail door I suppose
this needs to be there I guess there's
no other door to have I could do a
normal door staff door there we go oh
yeah that'll be good okay locked door
right about link okay and then once Wow
look at them go
alright speed up speed up speed up we
got to get hungry prisoners fed that's
the most important thing in our lives
right now
woo this is interesting because now I
get free for Mom whatever I want to do
nice yeah okay so now that we got that
those are built requires entrance we'll
get that in a second objects your jail
door I guess I guess this would require
jail doors pouring kitty kitty oh excuse
me that cropped up on me I apologize
okay so now I can make this into a
kitchen ha Bisky nice and then I can
make the canteen in here oh it's not
done yet okay so this needs a bunch of
ABBA Jack could you sue like hookers
cookers cooker look cookers cookers
cookers cookers cookers okay fridge ah
let's put it on the south side fridge
fridge fridge fridge sink sink sink
excellent placement no one's gonna be
inconvenienced by this at all and then
trash can by the door boink Andy boink
alright that looks good
failed need a fridge and a sink it's
almost there
bear with me and then in here we make
this into the canteen
okay we got that trouble bit a little
bit about okay we need some lighting in
this other place two lights blazed wink
point going to point boink
wait why can't I oh I couldn't do that
sorry
Bing Bing okay Bing Bing Bing Bing Bing
Bing Bing Bing all right that should be
good enough for that then I need to
connect it with the power in the
utilities grid electrical grid connect
that and that and then that and that
should be enough right
no these need their own power Bing bong
Bing bong Bing bong Bing bong I think
that's good enough for that and then it
needs it looks like it needs hype too
they're probably gonna give me a
tutorial about that later but I'm just
doing that preemptively so I actually do
what I need to do then this needs to go
all the way in here well I just need to
go all the way in here too but I'm all
right we got that done the kitchen is
doing well enough apparently it wants me
to do the floor differently well fine
let's get a nice white tile going on in
there quick they'll do matching oh let's
get let's give our prisoners something
nice let's give them a fancy tile that's
what they're looking for okay so that's
almost done now whoa hey whoa whoa whoa
it's not ready yet come on now it's not
ready
there's no food there's no food come on
what are you doing I don't even have
chefs all right cooks a buh buh buh buh
buh
I hope that's enough I don't know how
many I need all right now we need tables
how about wink wink wink wink wink wink
oh well they're done there poink poink
poink OH
Oh Inc bibbidi-bobbidi bibbidi-bobbidi
bibbidi-bobbidi okay and then they need
benches to sit on no that's a door
Abby boop boop beep boop beep Bob but
deep bong Bing bong Bing bong Bing Bing
Bing Bing Bing we point booing and
jeering tables now right here there and
there and there and there is that good
enough
did I do good I installed 4 Oh connect
the sinks to the water mains ok large
pipe need to go here like that is that
gonna nail did that do it
oh no that's that needs small pipe ok
small pipe Blair ok how about that let's
see if someone actually goes and do
their job is anybody gonna do their job
anybody over here huh
what yeah huh it looks like we need a
bin for the canteen you down here wait
leobens waiting spoink ok so we got our
we bins and we got the fridge is stocked
with nice food and not the water main
just yeah but there okay
yeah we did all that we needed to do
correct who the CEOs calling I hope he's
here to praise me and not to discipline
me you would not believe what I've just
been told why might why what happened is
there another fire Oh huh our guys were
dumping some of the old food stuff they
discovered packs of narcotics and
bottles of alcohol hidden in the crates
I don't believe it
I don't believe it at all we'd suspected
the Palermo family of smuggling into the
facility for some time now we
never been able to determine how some
days it doesn't rain it pours okay good
isn't that good
Don Victor Palermo also one of the East
Coast's most feared mob families uh-huh
the Palermo's eluded the FBI for decades
I didn't know that it was story time but
thanks grandpa
Anthony Palermo the Dons eldest son and
natural heir ran the day-to-day
operations Nikko tammer Eddie wasn't a
made man but was welcomed into the
family business when he married the Dons
only daughter Battaglia and sunny
Palermo Don's second son the runt of the
litter temper like a pit bull and only
half as smart their empire ran a
narcotics trade from Maine to Florida
that was until Anthony got called caught
in flagrant delicto I don't know what
that means
flagrante oh-oh-oh
it's connected I didn't know that shot
dead by a jealous husband unfortunately
for the family police at the scene found
12 kilos of uncut cocaine and Anthony's
sports bags that's a lot of cocaine whoo
and the evidence led straight to the top
Oh was that like in the picture and I
just didn't see it before
ooh that's no bueno oh it's all
connected I had no idea overnight
everything the Palermo family had built
up crumbled to the ground the FBI had
everything they need to do in sure
they'd all rot in jail
well then by vitaliy a-- you have a good
day
which leaves of Italia the Dons daughter
the only living member of the family who
isn't behind bars we don't know much
about her other than she was always kept
outside the family business but somebody
on the outside must have been sending
those drugs in somebody why would they
send him into the prison of all places
to send drugs why into the prison we
could have quite serious narcotics
problem on our hands here but we can't
deal with that just yet we've got our
kitchen and canteen up and running our
we'll work on preparing food for
everyone which should cool things down
I'm concerned that the fire was clearly
deliberate and we don't want a repeat of
that install a sprinkler system over the
new kitchen and canteen and connect them
to the water mains can-do boss will do
that all prisoners have needs those
needs directly impact how your prisoners
behave right now everyone is starving
under him that's what all the shouting
has been about food is one of their
highest priority needs and you ignore it
at your own peril a prison is just a few
failed meals away from a wall-to-wall
riot you can monitor the needs of all
your prisoners from the needs report
which you can normally access through
the reports icon at the bottom of the
right this report shows the combined
needs of all your prisoners red means a
lot of prisoners are angry about a
particular need not being met as you'd
expect food is red for virtually
everyone but these prisoners are also
very bored recreation needed and the
prison is also in pretty shabby state
which is reflected in their environment
and clothing needs ok it's your decision
as the resident prison architect which
needs to will you will try to attend to
first
you can install Tabata vision or sell to
keep you acrobat and hire some janitors
cleaned up the place or you can just
ignore your prisoners needs all together
and rely on force to keep your prison
under control I'll leave it up to you
wow that's it's so bizarre I really
appreciate I'll pause it real quick real
I really appreciate the fact that it
intermingles the story and functional
concepts of the game it brings like year
you end the game it draws you in with
the story that was unexpected when you
go into this who who would think that
there would be a story here that's
actually interesting and actually has
substance there but then it intermingles
it with the construction aspect of
actually maintaining the game itself and
that's very cool because at the core of
a game the gameplay has to be the
paramount so this could just be a prison
architect can be like the objective
could this be all make as much money as
you can but that's not all it is here
and that's really cool anyway that's all
I wanted to say about that anyway
carrying on back to the dick jokes and
fart boxes your
right where are we what are we doing
okay we need a new sprinkler system
objects sprinkler a blimp bump boink
boink Oh I doubled up Oh accidentally
doubled up the UH ah that's no bueno
I accidentally doubled up the lights in
the other place and the lights in this
place as well I didn't need that many
lights so I can actually destroy those
no I'm good okay that's gonna be fine
okay
so install a couple of sprinklers
connect the sprinklers to the water so
I'm gonna connect them with high-ups
where are they right there right there
so we're gonna connect another big water
main because we need them in both
categories then we need pipes going in
here I wonder if they'll if I have to
get right over them I'm not on it isn't
sure about that
here we go and that should do it
okay that should be it right that'll be
good okay hopefully let's see if that
goes have a damn um pom pom pom ba ba ba
boom ba ba dum boom boom I mean that
should be enough I'll goddamn it I was
one off yeah boink okay good enough good
enough good enough boink boink boink
okay got that and that should be good
alright so connect the sprinklers handle
the food needs are you prisoner handle
the recreational needs so where do I put
in things for stuff like free time oh I
guess I could put it in the yard that's
a thing
woo people are screaming whoa people are
not happy and this guy is tired and
resting he's standing in the middle of
the cellblock resting
astín huh-huh how you doing you you look
very unique compared to everybody else
who's happens to just be a circle
alright but everyone seems to be very
angry so I'm gonna give them something
to do you uh weights bench so they can
get stronger and eventually beat the
[ __ ] out of Alma guards that sounds good
you're up boink boink okay
TVs in their cells I can't put TVs in
all of their cells that wouldn't be that
wouldn't even be possible could I do
that I could probably do that maybe I
can do that maybe I'm gonna be the
benevolent prison architect and I'm
really gonna care
guys I mean that would be really
interesting I don't think that's what
I'm gonna do but here we go
and yeah yeah and especially this guy he
seems especially grumpy okay
only that cell block is gonna get TVs
because I can't be bothered to put TVs
in all of your cells that's just
ridiculous how could I do that that's
absurd that you would even think that
it's possible
uh-oh here comes the CEO hmm we've had
an incident in the showers oh no there's
a body actually there's two bodies
luckily for us we've got cameras in
there when you get a moment click on the
Polaroid in the showers and we'll take a
look at what happened okay let me get to
that in just a second I'm taking care of
the needs are they naked oh oh I know
who these are that's the guy that
married Vitali all right that doesn't
look a danger whoohoo danger is high and
increasing whoo all right you know what
I'm gonna give you all TVs because I'm
just feeling so darn generous actually
how about hey maybe bookshelves
maybe bookshelves I can't be bothered to
do everything for you guys oink oink
oink oink oink oink oink
bonk bonk Bing bong Bing oink oink oink
oink oink oink
okay you got books they got TV you're
gonna be better off because you're gonna
be learning who the holding cell doesn't
look very fun the holding cell looks
grimy as [ __ ] can I get some janitorial
staff or something yeah janitors all
right
buh buh buh buh beh beh beh beh beh beh
beh boingy boingy boingy boingy boingy I
don't know if placing him actually
affects what they do but hopefully it's
okay and it's gonna get a little cleaned
up because man this place is just rancid
oh my goodness gracious I didn't even
bother to look at that I thought that
was just part of their facilities oh my
god it's so gross
ah hell that's enough I'm gonna need an
army of you bastards
woo-woo-woo okay so they got that
hopefully some of these cells are gonna
cleaned up but I don't know about that
I'm wondering if because they're less
happy Oh calm down stop getting out
there you're gonna need to calm your
tits we got food on the way it's gonna
take a little longer I'm gonna get a few
more of these guys bonkie - boink wow
they are angry I'm gonna Robert Robert
Robert Robert Alda hopefully there's
enough food for everybody but I don't
know literally they're only in bacon but
at least the knees are going down the
old danger is decreasing which is nice
okay the recreational needs still need
to be addressed though I mean they got
TV is what more do you want
how more can I do I'm just one man
shopfront radio pool table like a gas in
the yard they could play pool in the
yard
can't they do that that's possible you
don't know um drain in the yard for all
the blood that's gonna be pumping out of
it I don't know
go have fun have fun you guys have fun
have fun all right so the UH so that's
good
okay handle the needs of your
recreational that's getting better it's
at 76% the environmental needs are
getting slowly up I just don't have
enough janitors just yet I'm gonna hire
a bunch of janitors and hopefully it'll
get cleaned up quicker and then I'll
fire some janitors so that I don't need
so many how can I sack you what are you
doing there
what are you doing this guy dead why are
you just bouncing on the radio you
weirdo
served 12 and a half of 72 years Wow
grievous bodily harm wow that is a wolf
whoa that is rap sheet holy crap
all right is it getting clean yet good
god it's still not clean my goodness
gracious these janitors need to hurry
the hell up
I said 60% oh I handled the needs the
food needs what's wrong with the food
needs but I did recreational needs are
done added the food needs go down damn
it
eat you bastards all right eat up maybe
do I need more cooks I think I might
need more cooks not that cooks cooks
cooks I just don't know how many cooks
you absolutely need 92 96 96 and bam
okay now we're gonna click on the
Polaroid before it can go wrong again
I owe you've shown an admirable
dedication in taking care of your
prisoner needs not that it's necessary
they're basically inhuman you'll
probably have noticed by now that the
major remaining gripe amongst the
prisoners is a lack of clean clothing if
you want to take care of this neat as
well you'll need to run a laundry
service to gradually provide all your
imp rates with clean clothing build the
laundry and hire more janitors to start
providing clean laundry to our inmates
yeah you'd think that'd be a necessity
god damn it do I need to do I need to do
that then now I'm gonna do the story
first I actually want to see I actually
want to see what this is about
or man I'll do this I'll do it and we
can build it up here this'll brought
work out better big laundry room big
laundry big okay so I think I got all
the major components they're just busy
getting the things in there I might need
more laundry baskets though but it's
getting there oh look they're sleeping
and they got fresh delivered prison
uniforms oh it's I don't the guys like
Leah thing yet I think they just
stripped down and they're all sleeping
naked that's probably what it is or at
least has the dirty stuff and they need
to get it later but I don't need to
worry about that right now I am worried
about other things that I need like
getting power to this thing why is there
no power yet why no power
why are you resting why no power oh god
I don't have enough power
whole building whoo ah that's new I
that's no good well I need more power
oh I didn't even know that yes that
crepes um whoo
I need to build more capacitors point
you'd be pointing at he boink boink
boink let's try that let's go those
built please can I get those built
please because we seem to be completely
out of power everywhere and there's
absolutely not enough water because
there's no power
oh god they can't open the doors oh okay
they got it okay they're good they're
good we got it okay that's fine
whoo now switch on oh bum ba-bum ba-bum
ba-bum oh they can't get out let him out
let him free please okay there we go
all right that's done resting right on
the power block good move brah good move
okay so the laundry room should be up
and running very soon as soon as they
finish the electrical development which
might not happen because that's not
close enough is it [ __ ]
do it like that okay but either way the
optional thing is done so let's get to
the story here oh jeez well this looks
grimy what's with the yellow stains ooh
oh hey how's it going what are you doing
with that really pretty looking knife
there oh he's so incredibly naked that's
amazing Oh alone boy fect uh-huh oh boy
why would anyone be alone in the showers
pouring it point at your victim step one
you took your time cut the [ __ ] I
never didn't know what that [ __ ] sister
of mine saw on you this her idea off the
old man ooh the plot thickens is that
what you think you fat [ __ ] I didn't
mean for him to get hurt I love him like
he's my own father I'm sick of seeing
this family brought down by your
stupidity the fire was meant for you oh
then consider this repaying the favor Oh
oh hi who the hell are you don't come
the same we both know you plan to take
me out one day oh hi yeah you always
were a smart guy Nico look where it got
you don't worry you won't feel a thing
Oh I told you watch your back Oh oh gosh
Wow whoa Wow
have you met Frankie before he's got a
unique talent with piano wire
Oh oh geez
whoa whoa whoa honestly by the time he's
finished they think it was suicide how
was how would that be suicide oh whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa that went
horribly awry there Oh
my goodness this game this game I love
it
oh he survived fantastic looks like the
Palermo family is running out of members
Wow you can bet the Palermo's we're
selling those narcotics on to every con
here
the guards are telling me they've seen a
lot of prisoners showing signs of
withdrawal since the fire I want you to
search every prisoner in every cell I
bet we find Palermo drugs all over the
prison well Wow
okay we're gonna end this one here wow I
love this game this game is awesome this
is amazing I had no idea and I loved it
I want to know so much more about this
story but either way thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know what
you think of the series down in the
comments below I may do a full
playthrough I have no idea this is just
awesome but thanks again everybody for
watching as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye Danny
Danny let me eat with you
piece of [ __ ] come on ha ha ha